[Music]
billy eilish doesn't have time for
haters
the 19 year old singer clapped back at
internet trolls in a video shared to
tick-tock on monday
billy shared one of the negative
comments she received that reads
is it just me or is billy in her flop
era like why does she suck now
the bad guy star basically laughed it
off in the video captioning it
literally all i see on this app eat my
dust my tits are bigger than yours
the song playing in the background is
our new single nda
[Music]
and in case your haters weren't keeping
track the music video for the song
already has more than 12 million views
on youtube
i did that this isn't the first time
billy has dealt with negative comments
in 2020 she told bbc breakfast there was
a point when she fully stopped reading
social media comments
because it was ruining her life the
cooler things you get to do
are the more people hate you it's crazy
what do we do about that how do we make
it better i don't know dude it's
crazy cancel culture is insane i mean
that's not what has been happening it's
just been like just the internet has a
bunch
of trolls you know and still billy isn't
letting the trolls bring her down
i'm breathing i'm alive i'm good she's
getting ready to release her new album
happier than ever on july 30th and if
her haters have
anything else to say they can look to
her seven grammys
which is so incredible spoke with the
singer backstage when she swept
the grammys last year billy crazy night
this turned into your night
i guess what does this mean to you i'm
dying
man i don't know it's crazy is this
beyond your wildest dreams yeah dude
this is surreal this is like a dream
oh my god the youngest person ever
to win those awards i'm
speechless speechless
enjoy the moment enjoy the night i am
and go take the picture without holding
all those grammys right
i will thank you man thank you guys
[Music]